In Juchitán, women are
considered a third gender, although
we assume that feminine role, we have this
female identity, which is what characterizes us. There
is the man, the woman, and the person, very
here we do not want to occupy the place of
the woman because the woman  it's the woman the
man is the man and the woman well it's
the woman from this space we work
so that our rights are respected
from our space a lot
[Music]
to greater
and bye
bye well after we have achieved a lot
because previously they hated us that we don't
want  As a woman, women
's clothing by sitech
now no longer supports what is not in the world,
it is not common and here they congratulate
you because you look good and also perhaps
their money has been their money
passing the years the years change
They change the way of seeing life,
everything that is happening with the
many here changes
[Music]
Now they say that it is the closest thing to
transgender
but with characteristics, their genes well,
many  cho for me this more unfair sex
at least that she is the most
normal
here people accept you and let you do
what you want to be
they see us as
we can get along with the whole
society
[Music
] most of most of  people here are
always healthy the many people there
say that luck
[Music]
wants to get your life we ​​live in my
house
and I am happy that I am in the middle of
two
[Music]
I am like a duality in both things
because I have
masculine strength  and sensitivity
in the Zapotec vocabulary a lot
means effeminate and fear
but my way of thinking that we
all have and I love that definition
because I believe that being a woman manages to
break that fear by becoming your
own identity and your own being
[  Music]
danny xhavizende the one with grains map us
from stories I changed the 'great one so I
don't finish it great chosen no
[Music]
[Music] well
I don't occupy the right that there are many of us we
sit them less next to the
others against  My self-esteem laughed,
well, very high, if I know what gender
this is and you're going to gas me the same
feminine roles but without wanting to be a woman,
the difference is a lot, I can't
have a woman anymore or feel taller than
a woman
because I'm reflecting myself  who
tried to do it yes but I don't feel
like the woman
well in
my dreams because it is to be someone in
life not just knowing what
dance clubs are and so on but I always
wanted to have a business in suits that
has always been my dreams and  I'm doing it right
now I have several outfits that
I'm going to put together waiting for me to
have a space in the market
[Music]
and making her walk a lot but she
should have in the future because she wants to
grow old with a partner I don't want
getting old sun and what better with me with my
current partner I don't want to die having
a partner
I've already spent a lot of that time that he
wants I like that man and wants to
be connected man let's go to the park
look for the man like  I already lived through all of this
and I had the privilege of
being one of the smallest among all
to invest, if not to be the first, I believe that
in 12 years I would reach 20, which were
seven more years, it was like mom already
gave me the  OK option, it
was a good job, it doesn't matter that you're a
lot, but with something that makes you independent
until you get to a sewing workshop,
the posture always catches my attention
when I return to like, about eight months
later, he let me be
[Music]
and that's how  If you were exercising
thanks to the presence of women, it is
very important because they are very hard-working,
so the women see that the
women work at the same time because they
have many of us, we have the support of the
women, the same population that
gives you the love of chiflan  because you look
pretty or because they blow you a kiss
because they tell you you know you look better right
now how you looked before or you don't
look like that duck anymore if you don't already look like
a swan no then obviously like you
you're going they believe it  do and you are
evolving you start to be a
very different person and you start just
stepping on the sky or living among the clouds
but on the contrary you start living
on earth in the same community
that begins to accept you it began to happen to you and
obviously you see  The world is very different, I don't
eat pink, but I do have colors.
I don't think that in other places it can be the
same thing because obviously the ism.
a little
different that obviously you can't
export one of the things to do when they
look the same
I have other sides
[Music]
the one from the cabin
via creative carisa of a day since you
want to take a crisis here why did
you come to bruce and take out the
ball  to stopped live indicates he she
then has been had the bird bach have
gone well and loved her bacán going badly from the
cow of mané cow divinity
gang to the initiates spent of him
or her
[Music]